here's another story this one came out
of the tennessean
you know now i am a tennessean here in
nashville so i saw this story
mom says woman killed in police shootout
had troubled
childhood no opportunity for change now
okay okay i'm not notice here in this
headline
i'm not getting any details about what
actually happened here's what i know
from the headline
the police killed this woman and she had
a
hard childhood okay now because i'm
seeing all these excuses in the headline
i'm going into this and i'm thinking
this woman must have done something
really bad because if you're
loading up all the excuses and clouding
up all the details in the headline
you know this is whatever this woman did
is really bad
turns out i was right the mother of a 31
year old woman who died friday after an
exchange of gunfire
doesn't say who shot first doesn't say
who pulled the gun first an exchange of
gunfire
where the nashville police officer says
her daughter was wrong for pulling a gun
oh oh you don't say pulling a gun on the
cop well maybe the cop was shooting at
her first
you think that was how nobody thinks
that's what happened but
still in the story it's still possible
that's what happened
but lisa holbert gooch who took in her
niece nico holbert at age eight
and adopted the girl and her younger
siblings said she is disturbed
by the actions of the metro nashville
police officer who stopped holberg
okay well what what's she just she's
saying okay yeah
the girl shouldn't have pulled a gun and
tried to shoot cops but
you know they kind of had it coming
because they had some very disturbing
actions okay what were those actions
gooch questions whether officer josh
baker followed basic traffic stop
safety protocols leading up to the
deadly shooting while police chief john
drake said saturday he believes baker
handled the situation property
she didn't have to die and he didn't
have to get shot gooch said in an
interview
as she watched video of the deadly
incident recorded on baker's body camera
gooch said she was concerned for both
the officer and her daughter
as she saw holbert exiting the vehicle
at the start of the traffic stop
so okay now that we're saying that the
problem here is
that the not that the cop did anything
wrong but that the woman
when she was pulled over at the traffic
stop got out of her car
why was she out of her car gooch said i
don't know that's a question for her
it's not a question for the cops
explaining she's always understood that
police don't typically allow someone to
exit the car as an officer approaches
holbert fled a parking lot friday
morning at the intersection of bridge
church pike in ewing drive
after shooting baker in the torso having
sustained injuries from the gunfire
holbert crashed roughly a block away
before being pronounced dead
so they watch the footage and
then they talk more about this the life
you know and the mother
and that this sort of how terrible it
all is and how unfortunate
it all is gooch said she was stunned to
see baker searching holbert's belongings
without appearing to take precautions to
remain in control of the situation
and after he determined she was not the
man baker was seeking
in the first place now what was
happening here
this woman was driving a car that
belonged to a man with outstanding
arrest warrants on felony drug charges
so the guy pulls her over apparently uh
holbert this in the article hobart
repeatedly ignored some of baker's
commands as he attempted to remain
cordial with her
the officer declined to stop her while
she went back into the car multiple
times to retrieve various items
it's like he let her do what she wanted
to do gucci said
the officer is now being accused of
inappropriate behavior
because he gave her the opportunity to
shoot him
that's that was the inappropriate
terrible thing for which this
officer should be investigated is he
wasn't harsh enough with her
now if he had been too harsh there would
be riots
right there if they were too harsh you
would have extortionist organizations
like blm
coming down and shaking down corporate
america for
tens of millions more in donations and
you'd hear this that he was a racist
but so he doesn't do that he's actually
too lenient and now
this woman and the newspaper are
accusing him
of inappropriate behavior because he was
too lenient
why'd you let her shoot you how how
wrong of you to let her
shoot you if the races were reversed
the story would not read that way that
is
an institutional sort of racism
that is the sort of thing we see in our
media and it is simply why
when you hear these claims from these
hucksters people like robin deangelo
who is making untold sums of money as a
race hustler
people like ibram kendy when you hear
them talk about institutional racism
you want to say yes there is there are
institutional racial problems
no question there is affirmative action
right that which disadvantages certain
people
based on their race and gives advantages
to other people solely based on their
race
and there are i mean even beyond that
there are racial issues in the country
no question about it racial issues that
are being inflamed
by people such as deangelo and
kendy and by the mainstream media
which never ever plays fair but it's
because
in this country the absolute worst thing
you can be called is a racist
it's it's why the whole institutional
racism thing
is so important to the left it's why
they're trying to push this
indoctrination
it's the worst thing you can possibly be
called in this country i think that's an
evidence by the way
that it's not a white supremacist
country right it's that the worst thing
you could be called is white supremacist
so
and the only race that you're allowed to
smear
in public that you're actually
encouraged to are white people and
specifically white guys
right that's why there's no patriarchy
the only group that you're able to smear
is dudes so you've got all of this built
in
and it bleeds into other areas of public
policy
as well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the michael knowles show to check
out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you